c'est pour un festival de création
numérique que les enfants de Droué
prennent les pinceaux l'artiste fasto
accompagne leur créativité c'est une
fraise qui se fait en plusieurs phases
il y a la phase du Big Bang qui est
vraiment où ça part dans tous les sens
où on vient juste faire un nuage de
couleur et puis ensuite de de cette
phase on va commencer à essayer de
définir un peu plus des des formes faire
apparaître des choses et puis de de ça
on va essayer de voir s'il y a des
personnages s'il y a des un univers qui
commence à apparaître assez
naturellement et que moi aussi je vais
je vais accompagner tout du long l'œuvre
est grandiose les contributions sont
collectives et l'imagination des enfants
fait le reste je suis un
bonhomme là je fait une j'essaie de
faire une cabane à côté de la maison
comme ça là et là par exemple l'étoil je
la rempl moi ce que j'aime dans tout ça
c'est peindre et créer des dessins des
dessins que je n'ai jamais fait nous
sommes en milieu rural dans le Perche au
vend deois la bibliothèque de Droué
bénéficie d'un programme départ
d'accès à la culture artistique et
technique l'idée c'est de faire
connaître un peu plus toute la matière
numérique au public alors on connaît les
ordinateurs les gens utilisent des
tablettes des des téléphones portables
mais la création vraiment artistique on
la voit peut-être moins en milieu rural
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
souhaité travailler avec un artiste
filmé et numérisé la fresque en
construction va servir de support
faire au ralenti OK